Lee Thomas: I really love more informal groups.
I've spoken at a few universities that were
just kind of a round table setting and I hope
when I'm done with my talk it's, bigger than
the book it's kinda just about me and the
book is a memoir of a few years and a few
difficult times.
But hopefully you guys can walk out of here
with a, with a better perspective on not only
the way that you approach work, but the way
that you approach life because I think every
moment is-is honestly and truly a gift and
you can do -- at any moment you can change
your life and-and make all of your dreams
realities.
So I always say I don't go anywhere without-without
a little TV --
[laughter]
and that's changed over the years 'cause literally
a little TV now really means a little TV --
[laughter]
but I mean I brought a little DVD for people
who might not know me or might have never
seen me on television. Here's a little bit
about what I do and a little bit of my story,
so please enjoy. It's about six minutes and
then I'll talk on the other side.
[DVD playing]
>>Lee Thomas: "I've been on the job for well
over a decade and I'm best known for my fun
celebrity interviews.
Is it 'cause she won an Oscar or 'cause she's
unbelievably hot? He goes, 'hot."
[laughter]
>>unidentified speaker: Would you dance with
me?
>>Lee Thomas: That's it, that's five times.
So far from Fresh Prince days.
[laughter]
>>Will Smith: You know I try and mix it up
a little bit, man. I try and mix it up.
>>Lee Thomas: If you were trying to describe
yourself to someone, 'Meryl Streep is,' how
would you finish this sentence?
>>Meryl Streep: A little happy.
[laughter]
It's alright. He's perfect.
>>Lee Thomas: No one is perfect. And little
did I know my biggest imperfection would become
my biggest story. Here we go.
When most people see me on camera, I'm fully
covered up, fully made up except for my hands
are exposed and they look different.
[pause]
Well, here's what I really look like. This
is
my face without makeup. I have a disease called
vitiligo. I was diagnosed with it about a
decade ago and it's gotten progressively worse.
In fact, one day, I may be completely void
of color; completely white.
Now one to two percent of the world population
has vitiligo, that's about 40 to 50 million;
and right here in the United States two to
five million people have this disorder, but
I'm fighting back.
>>unidentified medical personnel: "Ready,
Lee?
>>Lee Thomas: Yep.
>>unidentified medical personnel: Here we
go. Close your eyes.
>>Lee Thomas: Uh-hum.
[music and singing]
"Every little place seems to whisper Louise."
>>Lee Thomas: Over the past five years, I've
done various treatments including the latest
technology, light. Why am I telling my story
now?
>>unidentified voices: Wiggle your little
toesies.
>>Lee Thomas: Over the past few years I've
met or spoken with a number of kids and adults
that have vitiligo and many of them have told
me that seeing me unafraid to be in the public
eye and enjoying my job helps them.
So frankly, I'm doing this report because
a young man asked me to.
I know of a kid who wears a mask to go outside
and play 'cause he's afraid of being teased.
I've spoken to a woman who will not leave
her house because she has this disease.
[pause]
I know how they feel.
Vitiligo is not contagious and it's not life
threatening, but it is psychological warfare.
It's tough.
[pause]
So I hope that my story can be an extension
of strength and-and courage.
Yeah, the first 20 minutes of my day are spent
in a makeup mirror, putting on makeup, getting
ready for work, but I'm happy.
[pause]
This disease does not define me.
So if you're dealing with a health challenge
or vitiligo, live your life; just make sure
you have little fun along the way.
That's my story.
That story aired in November of 2005 and when
we televised my story, it got the biggest
viewer response my station has ever seen.
But that was only the beginning."
[rock music playing]
>>Larry King: We're back on Larry King Live.
The book is "Turning White: A Memoir of Change".
The author is Lee Thomas.
>>Lee Thomas: There was Larry and Montel.
[applause]
>>Lee Thomas: I also got a little TLC.
[music]
My book and my story have traveled the globe
and I've even started a support group with
part of the proceeds of the book going back
to a charity that I started.
But this journey has turned into so much more
than a guy with a disease. It's a life changing,
heartwarming mission as I show myself unmade,
unclothed, and unafraid for the whole world
to see.
[slow piano music playing in the background]
>>Lee Thomas: [speaking live] I used to look
at these pictures and it would be like devastating.
I would look at myself in the mirror and I
would think that people would see a monster
or people wouldn't shake my hand or they wouldn't
wanna talk to me or ostracize me, but as time
went on, I started to see myself differently.
It took a little bit of time, but where I
saw disaster, I saw something that was shockingly
beautiful in a way; it was almost like art
work.
And where I saw destruction and the end of
a television career I- I began to see that
this could be something that makes me so incredibly
unique that I am singularly defined, which
is what you want in a television career.
And-and I realize that people are simply looking
at a citizen, a man, a good person; they were
lookin' at a guy who works hard; they were
lookin' at somebody who tries to do the best
he can at everything. And no matter what the
obstacle was or no matter what they saw and
knew, they were lookin' at a good person 'cause
they were lookin' at me.
Hit them with that million dollar smile – gotta
love that.
[end of DVD]
[audience laughter]
>>Lee Thomas: You know, you look at my face
and you look at a disease like vitiligo which
can be very devastating and you think that
it would be a show stopper.
And for me, for awhile, it- it was. There
were times when I wouldn't go out of the house;
there were times when it was difficult for
me to see myself or whatever you define yourself
to be. But the outside coating is what you
are closely defined with and it was difficult
for me to see myself.
But as time went on and I struggled through
the different changes my body was going through,
I am so much more clearly defined as a man,
as a, as a father, as a brother; so much more
clearly defined as a African-American, as
an individual because I had to clearly define
myself in my own mind and in my own heart
that who I was and what I stood for past what
people saw.
And even past what I saw when people saw me,
which was the most important thing and the
most difficult thing that I think we all go
through.
Now I've-I've traveled all over the world
now talking about my story and sharing my
story in the book or-or just in-in speech
form, and I've realized in all this time,
I realized it pretty quickly that we all have
these things that we think make us different.
The thing that you say, "I can't do this because
of that", whatever "that" is.
It can be something that's easily defined
as a disease like vitiligo or it can be something
else. Some people think they're too fat, too
skinny, can't see, not tall enough, not short
enough, whatever especially when it comes
to hairdos or hair --
[laughter]
And all kinds of issues that we deal with
that-that stop us from achieving that dream;
that stop you from saying, "I can't do it."
And a lot of times you'll find that when you
really sit down with that disaster, you'll
find that the person that's stopping you is
always you. It's, you're the one that says,
"Well I shouldn't go. I shouldn't do." And
you have to find a way to work yourself out
of that, that self-imposed prison, 'cause
that's what I had found myself in.
So I'm gonna go over a few of the obstacles
that I face and not only that, I'll go over
how I-I overcame those obstacles and-and share
some stories as well along the way.
I always say to people that it was not, was
not easy; getting past those-those issues
are-are never easy. And I always go to the-the
darkest time for me, the most difficult part,
and I wrote about it in the book; it's a section
of the book that I actually posted on line
and it's called: Two Little Girls.
Because in the situation, in these real life
events, through these two little girls, it-it
helped me to understand myself better and
my situation.
One little girl about two or three, a little
cutie like the one that you have --
[laughter]
a little cutie, we were at -- I was at a playscape
and I was just walking up to-to -- I was actually
getting ready to go to work and I was on the
way and I walked up and the kids were playing
and I just came to, "Hey, let's go have some
kids for a second before I have to go back
to 'the news.'"
[laughter]
So I'm standin' at this playscape and this
little girl -- she bumps into me. She's kinda
not watching what she's doing, you know how
kids are, bumped right into my legs and I
looked down at her, she looks up at me and
she screams.
And if you've ever been around kids you know
there's different levels of scream --
[laughter]
there's the, "Okay I'll get to that in a minute
scream, tell your brother to stop." There
is the, "Okay, what did you just do and are
you bleeding." And then there's the, "Drop
everything and get the heck over there as
soon as you can because something's seriously
wrong with this kid," any adult would know.
That's the scream that she screamed. And she
screamed so loud, everybody at the playscape's
turning and lookin' at me. So I look down
and I go, I-I do what anybody else would do,
I reach out say, "What's wrong?" And she screamed
louder. And I realized that she was screaming
'cause she saw my face.
So what do you do with that? Because adults
are -- they're adults, they have their own
issues and their own problems and they bring
those to you and they drop it at your doorstep,
and then they can leave 'em with themselves.
Adults are no problem; they can do whatever
they want and I can handle it.
But a kid is pure honesty. I mean the little
girl was really afraid. So what do you, what
do you do with that?
So I-I backed up, I-I put my hands by my side
and I said, "Somebody come help this kid."
I was the one that was makin' her scream.
And when that happened, I went home and I
stayed home for two weeks and three days.
I'd only put on my makeup, I'd go to work,
I would, I would do everything that I had
to do; go to the grocery store, go any errands,
then I'd go home, I'd take off my makeup and
I'd stay home.
And for two weeks and three days, I lived
like that. And that's like prison to me, but
it was a self-imposed prison.
But I didn't wanna go around scaring small
kids, you know what I mean? And it was tough
for me to get my head around that. And I'm
sittin' there one afternoon after work watching
Oprah --
[laughter]
I'm not afraid to admit it. [clears throat]
And I look over by the TV and-and I see my-my
gym shoes; Converse not the Chucks, just regular
All-Stars, you know what I'm sayin'.
[laughter]
And I say that, "I-I just wanna go and-and
play basketball. I just wanna go play." And
I can't not go because of this; I can't let
this imprison me.
So I decide that I'm gonna go to the gym where
I've been goin' for the last [clears throat]
years with all the guys. And the guys have
seen it go from one spot on my hand, to a
spot on my scalp, to a spot on my face; they've
seen it progress and they don't care. As long
as I hit my jump shot and we win, we're good.
So I go to the gym and people look as much
as they always did, but nobody, no-no kids
were scared; no one cried so it was okay.
And I kept doing that. I'd go to places I
had been before; the same grocery store I
always go to and I start venturing out a little
bit more and it became okay again to go out
to the places I had been before.
And so one day I'm at my favorite grocery
store and I'm-I'm reachin', tryin' to get
the ranch flavored rice cakes 'cause I think
they're scrumptious --
[laughter]
and the second shelf from the bottom I'm reachin'
back and there-there, you know how people
tuck 'em in the back 'cause they're tryin'
to save 'em for themselves --
[laughter]
I don't get that, but I-I found it, so I'm
reachin' in the back to grab the one ranch
flavored one and I'm lookin' at the thing
and at the rice cakes and I hear a little
voice go, "You got a boo-boo?" And I go, "Oh
my God, its a little kid," right?
So [laughs] --
[laughter]
what's gonna happen? Am I gonna look up and
is she gonna freak out and-and is she gonna
go screaming through the grocery store and
everybody's gonna stare at me again? [sighs]
So I kinda froze there and then I go,
"Okay, I gotta do somethin'." She says, "You
got a boo-boo?" So I stood straight up and
I go, "No, it's not a boo-boo, I have vitiligo.
About one percent of the world population
--
[laughter]
Sixty million people but only 5 million are
in the United States. I was talkin' like a
three year old.
[laughter]
So I stop and I go, I go, "No, sweetie, it's-it's-it
doesn't, it's-it's-it's not a boo-boo. It's-it's
okay." And she says, "It's not a boo-boo?"
And I go, "No, it's not a boo-boo." She said,
"Do they hurt?"
[laughter]
And I said, I looked at her mom and said,
"What?" She goes, "Leave the man alone." I
go, "No, no, no this is good.
[laughter]
I just don't know what she said." She goes,
"She wants to know if it hurts." She said,
"Does it hurt?"
[laughter]
Oh yeah, it is, "does it hurt?"
So I-I-I bend down, I get on one knee and
I say, "No, no sweetie it doesn't hurt at
all. I'm fine." She said, "Does it hurt?"
I go, I go, "No." She reaches out and she-she
touches my face and she-she kind of looks
at it for
a second and she touches the dark part and
the light part and she goes, "Okay." And turned
around and grabbed a loaf of Wonder Bread.
[laughter]
Apparently it was, it's more interesting than
me.
[laughter]
But that's how kids are.
And-and in the-those two little girls was
the definition of dealing with this disease.
People have no idea what it is. I had no idea
what it was. So I freaked out completely;
fearful not knowing what it meant. Thinking
it was gonna be the end of everything. I freaked
out just as much as that little girl screaming.
But because the other little girl thought
she knew what it was, she had nothing but
compassion and-and love. She reached out and-and
healed a grown man's pain with one touch.
And because she thought she knew what it was,
because it was a boo-boo to her it wasn't
anything of fear. And I got compassion and
love and all these things that we all want
anyway even though sometimes we're too tough
to admit it.
[laughter]
So right there I knew that if I could handle
those two extremes that I could handle a life
with this disease.
Now before that I wasn't handling it very
well. It was difficult. I would be the, I
called it, I called it, "the angry black-white
guy."
[laughter]
'Cause people would look at me and I would,
I would give them -- you know that mean look
we all give when we're walkin' and we don't
anybody, everybody puts that face on.
[laughter]
When you're, when you're 6'2" and 190, it's
a little meaner, I guess.
[laughter]
If you're African-American, whatever, you
give 'em the mean look and you really look
mean.
So I would look at people and they would give
me the mean face or the "scared -- don't attack
me" face --
[laughter]
which is definitely not what I was tryin'
to get from people. But it was my own fear
thinking that they were gonna say something
that was gonna force me to be mean to them,
when I'm really not that kind of a guy.
So I said, "Why am I giving this mean face
to the public when it's really not even who
I am?"
So I said, "I'm gonna hit 'em with a megawatt;
that got me on TV."
[laughter]
The smile, baby. I'm gonna hit 'em with that.
Every time I just, that's, from here on out,
from this day forward, I'm not gonna be to
anybody, white, white guy, I'm gonna hit 'em
with the megawatt.
[laughter]
Know what I mean, bam!
Good timing!! You watch the news. Thank you
very much!!
[laughter]
And from that day forward since that little
girl, I decided that-that-that's what I was
gonna do. And everything changed.
People would come up and you're thinking it's
so weird like you'll be in a situation and
you'll automatically think you know what someone's
thinking, just by what they do. You don't
know where they've been; you don't know if
they're in some kind of physical pain; you
don't know if they have a false leg or a bum
eye; you just see a person lookin' at you
funny and you go, "Well that person obviously
has [boop]."
And all of a sudden it's the definition of
that person when you really have no idea what
that person's life is like or what they're
goin' through.
So I said, "I'm-I'm not gonna do that anymore.
I'm just gonna hit 'em with the megawatt smile
and see what I get." And I got a lot of good
stuff. People would smile back; people would
actually ask me, "Is that vitiligo? Is that
the same thing Michael Jackson has? I have
a cousin that has that." I got 98 percent
positive response from doin' that.
Oh but there was the two percent; the people
who had bad things to say, but most of the
time it was an adult that had their own issues
along the way.
I-I'll give you an example how flippin' it
around changed it for me.
I was at a gas station and you know when you're
pumping gas and there's that little space
between the-the mirror and the actual pump
where you can see the other person, but you
ignore them anyway.
[laughter]
And you pump your gas and they're like four
feet away from you pumpin' their gas, but
you swear you're on two different planets.
>>female in audience: Right.
[laughter]
>>Lee Thomas: So I'm doin' my, "You pump your
gas, I'll pump mine," thing and I'm-I'm thinkin'
about work or somethin' and I'm got a lady
across the way is like giving me the stink
face.
[laughter]
I call it the stink face because it's the
face that you make when you smell somethin'
funky.
[laughter]
You know that one?
She was givin me the stink face. And she's
like burnin' a hole on the side of my head
with the stink face.
[laughter]
So [laughs] I like, I hit her with the megawatt.
She's like. 'Foo!'
[laughter]
I'm like, "Okay. I'll just keep pumpin' my
gas."
So she finishes staring at me and-and walks
[laughs] around to go pay for her gas and
I'm still pumpin' my gas. So I-I hit her with
the megawatt again, "Hey."
[laughter]
And she goes, "What is wrong with you?"
I go, "Did do the [unintelligible]good enough?"
>>Female: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Lee Thomas: So I look at her and I go, "Look
besides the price of gas, I'm good."
[laughter]
"What's wrong with you?"
She's like, "Huh." And just walks off again.
And ever since, ever since that little girl
and ever since I changed my attitude I have
experiences like that where I walk away laughing,
and the person walks away with whatever they
walked up to me with. And they take it back
with them and go back to their families, God
help 'em ?
[laughter]
to deal with all of that. But I-I walk away
with-with dignity and humor intact; and those
are two really important things to me.
So I found that dealing with that in those
simple terms and-and taking those small bites
when it comes to that, is one way of-of my
way of finding a positive path in something
that could have been negative.
The other thing about it is the truth of the
matter is, there's-there's like 500 channels
or more, I mean you all have Dish or whatever
you have, and there's Google TV --
[laughter]
and there's like a zillion things that people
could watch. And in that landscape of global
television, 'cause that's what it is, and
in any instant we can call up a video from,
'China's Got Talent' and a million people
will view it in a few hours, a day. There's
a lot of things vying for people's attention
today and honestly, as a television personality,
I want people's attention.
And I-I was thinking it's-it's-it's -- attention
is a commodity in this world that we live
in now. And people will do it, get, try to
get attention at all costs.
I'll just say two words, "reality television."
Hello.
[laughter]
They will try to get attention at all costs.
I mean Paris Hilton -- what'd she do again?
[laughter]
But she is Paris Hilton you know what I mean?
I mean attention at all costs is worth a-a
lot in this day and age 'cause it's really
about just having that bit of some person's
mental property in there where they go, "Oh
yeah, I know that guy." And that can sell
on-on whatever platform we have -- on the
Web or whatever.
And honestly I thought that this was gonna
be the end of my little bit of television;
my small bit of TV real estate.
I-I got vitiligo when I had a job in Kentucky.
I got a job in New York and hid that I had
it. I only had it on my hand and on my scalp
when I got to WABC in New York. Then I would
just put makeup on it and nobody-nobody knew.
When it got on my face completely freaked
out. I mean was walkin' in Central Park talkin'
to myself, "What am I gonna do? Go to trucking
school or what am I gonna do now." People
were lookin' at me like, "Why does that guy
dressed so nice to be homeless?"
[laughter]
"No. No. I'm just talkin' to myself. Don't
worry about it." Sat on the bench and I really,
I took my whole lunch break the day I-I was
completely diagnosed saying, "This is vitiligo;
it's not curable. What are ya gonna do?" My
whole lunch break I was sittin' in the park
talkin' to myself, thinkin' that it's over.
I worked my way through college, I paid for
it myself, I got my job in TV and I had been
workin' ever since doin' pretty much entertainment
reporting and anchoring which is exactly what
I wanted to do; dream come true kinda scenario.
So when I got the diagnosis, I thought it
was done. How can a guy with this kind of
disease with this darker skin, and the-the
transition is gonna be crazy and one day it's
gonna be, I'll be sittin' on some island with
a hat that says, "Press," on the front; one
of those newsboy caps. "Well I used to be
on TV."
[laughter]
So I could impress people at a bar, I mean
that's what I thought was my future. And-and
it was hard for me to-to shake that-that image
in-in my head.
But honestly, this situation that has happened
to me, this disease, has made me, not only
the global spokesperson for this disease,
which is a very difficult disease for many
people in a lot of countries. There are still
countries on this globe that think vitiligo
is leprosy, and ostracize or even worse to
the person who has it in that culture.
So I've become the face of this disease on
a global, a global platform. And also I-I
have become, for whatever little bit of mental
real estate that means, when people-people
go, I've had people come to work for me that
say, "You know my dad knows your story; he
read your book and-and-and he asked me if
I was comin' to the station to work with you.
You're the first person I sought out when
I came here because I had heard your story."
I was at an airport in Germany and this guys
comes up and, "Lee Thomas!" I'm thinkin',
"Oh man!"
[laughter]
I'm gonna be taken down in Germany.
Where's my mom's numbers?
[laughter]
But he-he gives me hugs. "I see you on the
Larry King. You are incredible!"
[laughter]
And I'm like, "that's awesome," 'cause I really
thought I was going to go to customs on this.
[laughter]
He gives me a hug.
It's incredible how now I've become a-a television
personality from Detroit without a doubt.
But now people know all over the globe from
Australia to Taiwan who I am.
I've spoken to groups in, last month I was
in Italy; month before that I was in Toronto;
I've been goin' all over the country and the
globe for that matter. I'm sharing my story.
And I can say that what I thought was gonna
be the worst, devastating, show stopping thing
in my life has turned out to be one of the
biggest blessings that I've ever had.
And it's incredible to even say that now.
It feels funny even coming out, but it's the
absolute truth. It's made me so much of a
better man than I was before in the shallow
television world.
[chuckles] I'm doin' an interview with a-a
Hollywood actress and-and she's got a pimple
[laughs] --
[laughter]
Like right by her nose, like right in this
area. [laughs] And she -- like the makeup
artist comes in and the other makeup artist
comes in and she says, "Oh my God, can you
see it?"
[laughter]
Mind you this is in between my interview and
someone else's interview so I have to sit
in the chair and I'm sittin' there goin' tryin'
not to laugh. She's like, "What?" I'm like,
"If you knew what my face looked like under
this makeup, that pimple's like small potatoes."
She goes, "I know, but you have to look -- this
is Hollywood." And I go, "I know. It's Hollywood.
It's the way the people view you."
But-but the thing that could have most devastating
for me turned out to be the-the most incredible;
the most incredible.
I-I say, I-I share that story especially when
I speak to people at companies because sometimes
when you're in the midst of a situation, a
difficult task and you look at the difficulties
of that task, you-you pull yourself away from
it and pull the emotion away from the task,
and you might find a gem in there that you
would not have noticed because it was a such
a devastating, bad thing two seconds ago.
But if you pull yourself away from it and
try to look at it at every angle, different
angles, all of a sudden an angle will come
out that you never would have thought of.
I mean sittin' at this table I still can't
believe I still have my job. It's incredible!
A hundred and twenty-five thousand people
every 15 minutes watch the number one morning
show in Detroit 'Fox Two News, the news that
works for you.'
[laughter]
But --
I mean I never would have thought --
[laughter]
that —like Austin down there/
Thank you.
I never would have thought that I would be
able to maintain my job and-and look like
this and have this disease and slowly change
over time.
But it's turned out to be the singular defining
thing that defines not only me, it defines
how great my boss and our general manager
are, because from day one they've been nothing
but supportive.
'Cause I-I, went it started getting worse
when I couldn't hide it anymore, I'd go into
my boss' office and I would say, "I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to stay on TV doin'
this." And she goes, "We love what you do.
We love your work. Whatever you decide to
do, we're gonna support you. But we want you
on our television station." I'm like, "Cool.
Just checking. Good to know."
[laughter]
And I always, especially when I talk to younger
kids, I-I try to tell 'em to have-have what
I call "their-their high council" because
there's a lot of people who say a lot of stuff,
talkin' about attention. You can hear opinions
from anywhere. Just click on your computer,
Google something, you got a zillion opinions
on everything.
But you-you can't listen to them all. You
have to pick your high council and listen
to those people. And it's usually someone
that has a stake in you; someone who has some
kind of emotional stake in you: family or
just a really good friend who is that honest
person. And for me it-it's my sister, Beverly.
She-she has made me more money.
One time I was tryin' to negotiate a contract
and I called my sister and she goes, "You
can't live on that! Ask for 20 grand more!"
[laughter]
I go, "Are you serious?"
She goes, "Just try it; see what happens.
But be nice when you say it."
[laughter]
I called her back I'm like, "Get outta here!"
"Five G. Ahh!!!"
[laughter]
But my sister's always been very honest with
me and I said to her, "I don't know if I can
continue to do this. I don't know if I can
stay doin' this."
And she goes, "Why? Has-has the big boss,"
(that's the guy in the biggest office, I call
him "big boss") – the general manager ?
[laughter]
"Has the big boss said anything?" And I go,
"No. They've been, they're still very supportive."
And she go, "Well has-has the boss said anything?
Has she said anything?"
My boss is the news director, my direct boss.
And I go, "No. She's, they've been very supportive."
She said, "Have any of your co-workers said
that you need to quit because you have vitiligo?"
I go,"No. Not to my face they didn't."
She goes, "Well the only person I hear sayin'
it is you. So stop sayin' it. Just stop saying
it. Stop sayin' it; stop thinking it; stop
acting that way. Act like it's your job and
that you're gonna have it for a long time,
even if you don't believe it right now. Just
act that way."
And it changed; and once again just a simple
thing as perspective.
I-I beg to say, I don't beg to say, I'll just
say it --
[laughter]
that you can't define somethin' as negative
until you define it as negative. Up until
that point it's just something that happened.
Up until that point, it's just something that
happened.
You can walk out of this room right now and-and
slip and-and-and fall right there in the hallway.
You can get up and go, "I cannot believe that
just happened. Why does this kind of stuff
always happen to me?"
But what if while you were slippin' and fallin'
in the hallway and doin' all that stuff, there
was something in your office that much worse
that would have happened if you wouldn't have
fallen in the hallway?
But you don't know that because you're too
busy worried about what just happened in the
hallway to know that you just avoided something
much worse. That if you slipped and fell in
your office and hit the side of your desk
that you'd be at the hospital.
So it's all about the perspective on the situation;
'cause things happen in life. Nothin's gonna
be smooth sailing ever. It's all about how
you prescribe feelings or emotions around
that situation. And-and what you, what weight
you give it.
I always say to people that if you, I have
this thing I call the five second-five minute
rule; you get five seconds to let it all out
when something happens. Because things happen
and you have emotions and you have to deal
with those emotions. You take five seconds
and sometimes you may wanna go somewhere by
yourself and just let it all out.
Whatever you wanna say, however you wanna
say it, let it happen. Stop at five seconds
and then take five minutes to get over it
-- if you need five minutes to get over it.
Whatever it takes: call your best friend,
write it in your journal, which I highly recommend,
but take those five minutes and really get
over it.
I don't mean go over it. I mean get over it.
Meaning that situation happened; it's not
defining who I am; it's just the situation
that happened. And if you could figure out
why it happened, do that whatever the situation
is.
And then change that situation's outcome by
the end of that five minutes and go, "You
know what? I'm glad this, this, and this didn't
happen and that's the only thing that happened."
And make it something better in that five
minutes. And then after five minutes, let
it go. L-I-G. I was interviewing Snoop Dog
once he said, "L-I-G, brother --
[laughter]
And I said, "What?"
"Let it go."
[laughter]
Let it go. Don't go back and go, "Man it's
this-this happened two weeks ago and it's
happening again." In two weeks, let it go.
Let it go.
If you go over your life and there's some
things you do over and over all the time;
happen every day. You get up, you take a shower,
you brush your teeth, sometimes you don't,
sometimes you don't take a shower. You're
still alive; you still have the opportunity
to live. Don't prescribe all these bad things
to that one moment so it's gonna devastate
your life.
And-and in five minutes really let it go.
And sometimes that's hard to do, because what
happened is tough. And what I do is I, it-it
sounds kind of funny, but I call it a-a "happy
thought." And whatever that "happy thought"
can be -- and for me I have a two-year old
daughter and she cracks me up; just lookin'
at a picture of her. [laughs]
But whatever that is for you for-for a guy
I was at a, at a, at a company and I was asking
people what could be your happy thought for-for
a guy it was a car that he was workin' on
'cause every time he goes to work on that
car. it just, it just makes him, makes him
happy.
It could be your mom; it could be your dog;
it could be your house; could be a walk on
the beach you had with your sister, your mother,
your girlfriend, your wife, your husband.
But whatever that happy thought is. after
that five minutes, go there and live there
for a couple minutes so that you come out
of it on the other side of it realizing that,
"I'm still here. They're still here. Life
is still good. I'm gonna go home and my daughter's
gonna give me a hug."
Whatever just happened is small potatoes compared
to her well-being.
I mean I might have fallen in the hall, somebody
might have said something a bit flippant to
me about the way that I look, but they don't
sign my paycheck and what they said is not
gonna hurt my daughter [someone in audience
coughing] or hurt me. So I move right on and
I don't, I don't harbor, I don't harbor any
of those emotions.
I just like sharing-sharing stories in that
way because maybe that's somethin' that you
can take with you as you try to overcome obstacles
not only in your life, but at work.
It makes, it makes the things that happen
at work so much smaller when you big picture,
when you big picture something.
Another thing that I end up talking about
--
[pause]
>>female voice: Yeah. Come on in.
[laughter]
[several people talking at same time.
>>Lee Thomas: Another thing, another thing
I end up talkin' about a lot is-is Michael
Jackson. He had the disease vitiligo; he talked
about different venues and for some reason
people just will not believe it; will not
believe it.
I say to people, "What if you were the most
popular person on the planet? Your album "Thriller"
is out and there's this album cover with you,
baddest dude in the world, women are fainting
at your sight, albums are selling like hotcakes,
but you have a secret.
You really look like this instead of that.
What do you do for all of those millions of
fans, for all of those millions of fans? And
if you're in Hollywood, you hide it. You fix
it. That's the way they do things; they fix
it – they fix their hair, nose, butt – everything
else.
[laughter]
Hair, you fix it.
So I-I understand why he hid. I'm pretty sure
that's what the people around him told him
to do was to hide. I understand how it became
more difficult for him.
I also understand why the people who loved
him protected him, because people do it for
me. It's so funny.
I was at a, I was at a gas station tryin'
to get gas and I'm, I walk in to pay for my
gas and the guy behind the counter goes, "Oh
come on, you cut this out." I'm like, "What?
I'm just thirty on pump three." "No, no, no
stop this with the face thing. You have, you
have the Halloween mask on." I go, "Dude,
it's not Halloween really. Thirty on pump
three."
[laughter]
He's like, "No, no, no take this stuff off
your face. That is the best makeup I've ever
seen. Take this off your face now. Hey come
here, look at this guy. Come here. Come here."
Some other guy comes in, "Oh look at this.
Is this a Halloween mask?" [laughs]
I said, "Really, just want gas. You guys are
really funny --
[laughter]
should be on Letterman, but I-I want, I want
gas."
[laughter]
"No, no, no, no, no."
So the guy, there was two ladies behind me
and another guy. The guy literally pushes
me out of the way and goes, "Do you know who
this is?"
[laughter]
"Do you know who this guy is?"
And I go, "Please don't. No. No."
[laughter]
"Don't go that route, please. Please I just
want-want thirty on three please."
[laughter]
And the lady's like, "I can't believe they're
sayin' that. There must be somethin' you can
do. You should call the Problem Solvers. Get
a camera out here. They don't know you're
Lee Thomas."
[laughter]
The guy's like, "He is Lee Thomas."
And I'm like, "Oh my God."
[laughter]
And then they realize that-that I, that it's
me; that I have a disease; not that I'm Lee
Thomas. But I think the three people on the
other side of the counter would mug them if
they didn't just give me my gas.
[laughter]
So they-they take my $30 from me and say,
"Thank you."
And I walk off and [laughing] going, "You
people are great, like hey follow me around
all the time."
[laughter]
Very entertaining."
But the-the way that people react to the way
that you look is-is incredible. So could you
imagine bein' Michael Jackson with all that?
I mean really.
I, when I first got the disease, I got one
spot. I got a spot on my scalp, got two on
my scalp and then I got one on my hand probably
the size of a quarter. And so this was one
of the worse ones that happened while I was
here in Detroit.
And it was like early September and I wore
one glove to do my live shots. So I'd hold
the-the mic with the gloved hand so I could
shake people's hands with this hand. And the
gloved hand was covering the spot. Hee-hee-Hee.
[laughter]
And so I was reading on Michael Jackson and-and
Michael Jackson's friend and one of his friends
had said that the reason he wore the one glove
that became a fashion statement is because
he had a spot on his hand and he couldn't
put makeup on 'cause it kept coming off. So
he made this, he just didn't wanna wear a
glove he-he was an entertainer so he had to
wear a bedazzled glove.
[laughter]
But-but he was really just covering the vitiligo.
Then for me it went from one hand to two hands
and I tried the two glove thing, but it really
wasn't that season for that either. People
were writing in, "Why is Lee Thomas wearing
gloves and it's not cold?"
[laughter]
Thanks a lot Internet people.
Skin! [hits the table]
But so people were writing in so I had to,
I had to get rid of the gloves. I had to go,
"You know what? They're just gonna see the
spots on my hands."
But Michael Jackson, remember, he went to
two gloves; went to two gloves for a long
time.
The other thing that I end up vouching for
him a lot for is that one of the procedures
for this disease is that if you get it in
over 80 percent of your body, meaning that
there's only 20 percent pigment left, that
you bleach out the rest.
But the problem with that is you have to continue
to bleach because your, even though it's not
makin' a lot of pigment, your body still tries
to make pigment. So you'll get spots of pigment
all over your body.
And but once, and also once you bleach the
rest out so that you're uniform, your skin
becomes really sensitive to the sun. So you
have to use hats and umbrellas and scarves
to cover up when you go out in the sun. I
have to carry a hat everywhere I go because
you can see through my scalp that it's gone.
And it-it burns like that [snaps fingers].
I can't go cover a U of M game or anywhere
for that matter on a hot sunny day and stay
out in the sun for a two hour newscast. I
have to get in the truck and get in and out
of the truck 'cause it'll-it'll really give
me a severe sunburn.
And he had to deal with the same thing. He
had to deal with the same thing. But it all
fell in the weird category and he never really,
and no one ever really addressed it with him
in any in depth fashion.
So as I tour the world, I end up going, "Yes,
yes, it's one the pro- yes he bleached his
skin." Wow, vouchin' for Michael Jackson,
huh?
[laughter]
So one day I'm-I'm-I'm-I'm at my desk I think
it's CNN or one of, or USA Today or one of
those, one of those newspapers websites whatever
had called and I answered the phone and they
go, "Well, Quincy Jones says Michael Jackson
wants to be white. Do you have a comment?"
I'm like, "You want me to refute Quincy Jones?"
[laughter]
I'm like, "Okay, first of all he's one of
the best music producers EVER!!
[laughter]
I love him. There's nothing I can do. He could
crush me like a bug without even thinking."
[laughter]
"Second, he's off his rocker. The guy had
a disease. Michael Jackson had vitiligo. He
was not trying to be white. He was just turning
white; it wasn't a choice."
He would've never said he wasn't an African-American.
He addressed the disease to Oprah Winfrey
and to Martin Bashir in two different interviews
that he has so much other stuff going on that
he said, "I have vitiligo," and the next sentence
was, "So you have sleepovers."
It was just not ever really addressed.
So it gives you a different perspective and
for me, it gave me a different perspective
being that I cannot hide, because if you hide,
it lets people draw their own conclusions,
and man their conclusions can be way out there,
way out there.
So not that he did the wrong thing, because
I think each person has to define what's best
for them. And I'm not saying the way that
I treated this situation or I treat this situation
is the right way to do it.
But he was a great example of what not to
do for me. I mean when he died, I had a whole
'nother set of interviews where people wanted
to just talk about vitiligo, and-and hopefully
one day people will stop-stop asking me because
it's understood; or even better, even better,
it's cured. It could be, it could be cured.
How we doin' with time?
>>commentator: So we-we have, we have about
10 minutes left --
>>Lee Thomas: Okay.
>>commentator: So if you have a [some coughing]
couple other key things or if you just wanna
just open it up to questions --
>>Lee Thomas: Um-hum.
>>commentator: it's up to you.
>>Lee Thomas: I'm sure you-you guys might
have some questions, yeah? No, yeah, no?
But well I'll leave you with this real quickly;
real quickly.
As I, and you can tell I talk for a living,
so --
[laughter]
but if-if-if you walk out of this room with
anything, hopefully you'll walk out realizing
that there are-are some insurmountable things
or seemly insurmountable things that happen
throughout a lifetime that make you think
that you cannot do, and I say not only do,
but dream.
Because not only is it gonna make you happy
to do and live your dreams, but I really feel
like we need each other to live our dreams,
because I wouldn't be drivin' a car if it
wasn't for the guy who dreamed of makin' the
car. Not only that, dreamed of making it affordable
for everyone to be able to drive a car. I
wouldn't be sitting here if Al Gore didn't
in-invent the Internet for us to use.
[laughter]
That's still funny, isn't it?
Years later, that's still funny.
[laughter]
But I only say that to say that it's-it-it's
up to you to figure out how to get past your
obstacles at work, at home, whereever you
are. But we help each other in every way.
If you subtract money from the equation, and
I know that's hard to do so please bear with
me for a moment. If you subtract money from
the equation, there's not one part of your
life that's not bent on somebody else, that's
not up to someone else.
Did you grow all the food you eat? Yes and
no. Somebody else did. Did you make the clothes
you're wearing right now? Yes and not. Somebody
else pretty much made those.
Anything, and you go get in your car, did
you drill for oil and turn it into petroleum
and put the gas in there for you to drive
home?
I mean you look in your refrigerator and it's
like a slice of the globe. You can have oranges
from somewhere in South America; you could
have containers from China; all these things
that you use on a daily basis that you do
on a daily basis from-from haircuts to shoes
are based on someone helping you; subtracting
money from the situation.
So I say not only find a way past your difficulties,
living your best life actually helps me and
you and you and you and you; it helps each
other, especially in a work environment like
that, like this where you guys are. It-it
literally does; it literally does.
'Cause you know you're in a work group situation
and someone has a problem and that problem
becomes the one where they go and talk about
the problem to the next person, and that problem
becomes a problem that's talked about by the
next person and it goes.
Then the next day you come to work and you
find out that you have a fake leg and you
really couldn't walk when you made that decision
'cause that's how far the story has gone;
when if the first person with the problem
didn't call it a problem, then it wouldn't
be a problem. It would be a situation that
we're all helping with.
So it's just a perspective thing that changes
lives. And it, and it changed mine. And it
did change mine.
So could we have some questions?
[pause]
Anyone?
>>commentator: Please.
>male #1: I've heard looks are everything.
Is that --
[laughter]
[many people talking at once]
or is it something dumb?
[laughter]
>>female #1: Well I just have a little one.
How do you, how is the reaction then because
you do deal with so many celebrities --
>>Lee Thomas: Um-hum.
>>female #1: has the reaction in your journey
been different in that spotlight with celebrities
--
>>Lee Thomas: It has.
>>female #1: versus us everyday kind of people.
I walk in and this has happened more than
a few times since, but the first time it happened,
I walk in to interview George Clooney for
"Leatherheads", which I didn't think was a
bad movie; I thought it was okay. But I just
like Clooney.
And I walk in the room he goes, "Hey, Lee,
man I knew you were comin' and I've been watchin'
your story; you were on 20/20 and I saw you
on Larry King and I have one of my best friends
has vitiligo and he's had it all his life.
And he almost stopped acting because he had
this, so what you're doin' is a good thing;
don't stop doin' that; just don't stop."
Before I even sat down in the chair he said,
"Don't stop doin' that. You're doin' a great
job at that. Keep doin' that."
And I go, "You're George Clooney."
[laughter]
And I just start laughing. He goes, "Yeah,
but I pay attention." He's just an astute
guy; he pays attention to the news as well.
And it was just weird that the minute of my
interview was George Clooney talkin' to me
about me. So naturally I go, "So he was talkin'
for the first minute --
[laughter]
do I get another minute here 'cause I only
have seven minutes, George, and you steal
one of my minutes talkin' about me --
[laughter]
"unless I can use that." He goes, "Yeah, yeah
use it. Use it" I'm like, "Okay good 'cause
--
[laughter]
I only got a few minutes here, brother."
That happened with Ashton Kutcher; it's happened
with Loretta Devine, it's just what-what's
the guys name, just was in there, his name
was Donal Logue. Same, he-he said, he's a
great actor isn't he?
[laughter]
He's a great actor.
But anyway he was just in the studio the other
day and he did the same thing. He goes, "Oh
man I saw you at, I thought you worked in
Atlanta." I go, "No, I've been here in Detroit."
"So when you told your story it was from Detroit?"
And I go, "And we're live with Donal Logue,
we're gonna talk about his television show
– right, Donal?"
[laughter]
"Right."
Like of course we are.
[laughter]
That's the-the thing that's made it a little,
a little weird when people -- they've seen
my story and-and I've-I've never had a-a negative
response from-from the celebrities who see
my story, when they bring it up.
Now there have been some celebrities that
don't wanna shake my hand for whatever reason;
it's happened.
I went, I'll tell you this story 'cause it
turns out well 'cause I'd never dump on anybody.
But I went --
[laughter]
I went to sha-shake Seth Green's hand and
I shake his hand and he looks at my hand he
goes, "What's your deal?"
[laughter]
And I go, "What's my deal? What do you mean?"
He goes, "What's with the white hand and black-black
face thing?"
And I go, "Oh yeah, yeah, yeah." I go, "I
have a disease called vitiligo."
He goes, "Vitiligo, I know what that is."
He goes, "It turns you completely,"
I go, "Yeah, completely."
He goes, "You know one of my buddy's had that
and he started gettin' spots everywhere; he
freaked out." He says, "Is that what that
is?"
I go, "Yeah, yeah." I go, "So you've heard
of it."
He goes, "Yeah, Michael Jackson had that man."
And I go, "I know."
[laughter]
And I go, "Can I get another minute here?
'Cause Seth, you just killed one of my minutes
--
[laughter]
'cause they're really tight on time."
But it's been, it's been incredible; it really
has; it really has.
>>female #2: I wanna say like how his like
specifically to the African-American community
has reacted to the disease since it's, I think
for African-Americans much more obvious --
>>Lee Thomas: Um-hum. When we have it.
>>female #2: when people of color, yeah.
>>Lee Thomas: Yeah, it-it's-it's been very,
very embracing. I made a best-seller list,
my book made a best-seller list. It was the
Essence Best Seller List which was very cool
--
[laughter]
It was very cool. So the ladies at Essence
are readin' my book.
[laughter]
What are you doin', girl?
So no, it's been really --
[laughter]
it's been really, really cool because I think
that a lot of times, whatever community it
is, but especially the African-American community,
didn't have a lot of information about the
disease. And Michael Jackson when it comes
to the disease 'cause they interviewed him
before Essence specifically and-and Ebony
and all-all of the African-American publications,
but no one really talks to him about this.
So I've been in Jet Ebony, I've been in Essence,
I've been all these magazines and they featured
me in different ways, and on B-E-T and all
this stuff kind of givin' people the-the real
skinny on vitiligo and-and-and everyone of
'em asked about Michael Jackson.
Because it, the other thing it helped me do
is to clearly define myself as an African-American
man. 'Cause no matter much my pigment goes
away, I'm still going to be that just as much
as-as-as someone's Italian-American or-or
Is-Israeli-American, or whatever you might
be. It's not gonna go away just because your
pigment goes away.
So I had to clearly, clearly define that.
It's funny 'cause I was on a plane, a long
plane ride back from London, and a guy, a
guy was sittin' next to me; he ended up being
a college professor at State, and so we were
talking back and forth and after he figured
I was cool he goes, "Can I ask you a question?"
And I go, "Shoot."
He says, "Are you, are you a black guy turnin'
white or a white guy turnin' black?"
'Cause I'm on a, I'm on a plane and always
wear a hoody and alls you can see if pretty
much this, right?
So he sees this and my hands and he goes,
"I have no idea. Which one are you?"
And I go, "I'm a brother, man.
[laughter]
Don't make me prove it." [raises his hand]
But it's really a-a question when your, when
your pigment goes away. And a lot of people
that not only African-Americans but there's
a large Indian population. There's one city
in India specifically that has a large portion
of their population that has vitiligo. And
even though their skin isn't as dark as mine,
it's still devastating, a devastating disease
when you start watching your pigment; especially
an-an African-American man, a dark-skinned
African-American man when you are so clearly
defined by the color of your skin. So when
it starts going away you have to go, "Okay."
>>female #2: So it could be the other way,
too? It could be let's say you're of-of European
descent ?
>>Lee Thomas: Um-hum.
>>female #2: your pigment could become darker
--
>>Lee Thomas: Um-hum.
>>female #2: too so – oh really?
>>Lee Thomas: There is a disease, not vitiligo.
>>female #2: Okay.
>>Lee Thomas: But there is a disease that
can turn, make your pigment get hyper-pigmentation,
where you get darker than, than you would
want to be. But it's not gonna go like a person
with-with-with white skin gets dark like an
African-American.
>>female #2: Okay.
>>Lee Thomas: It would get dark like a dark,
dark tan; as dark as they could get. You know
what I mean?
>>female #2: Yeah.
>>Lee Thomas: So there-there is diseases that
can, that can do that as well.
[pause]
>>male #1: As I said earlier I see you, I
always see you on the news quite a bit ?
>>Lee Thomas: Um-hum.
>>male #1: if you, if people hadn't seen your
story they would never know.
>>Lee Thomas: Right.
>>male #1: Have you ever given any thought
to, is there any, I mean what's the reason
why you --
>>Lee Thomas: Don't?
>>male #1: Yeah.
>>Lee Thomas: The reason why I-I still wear
makeup on television is because I'll talk
to everybody and their granddad about it,
but there is a portion of the population who
can't get past it. There are people who can't
hear what I'm saying because of it.
It's funny because I-I can tell when somebody
just can't get past it 'cause I'll be standin'
in a group of people and one person will be
staring at like my ear the whole time --
[laughter]
goin' like this.
You can tell they think, "What is that? It's
on his ear, and it's on his neck and look
at his scalp, it so --
And they're just gone.
And because of that, if-if I were to do that
to where it distracted from whatever I'm talking
about, I'm a journalist and the story isn't
really about me, it's about whatever I'm talkin'
about. So if they're payin' attention to me,
I'm not doin' my job right.
[sound of phone ringing]
So that's why I still wear it. But Hugh Perkins
swears up and down, "You should just go on
TV --
[laughter]
If I made as much money as you make, I would
just go on TV, and if I go bounced, I would
call it.